les villes grandissent se gonflent leur
nombre d'habitants est sans cesse en
augmentation à rennes de nouveaux
quartiers sont nés avec leur hlm
cela est vrai notamment dans la zone de
breaking où la municipalité consciente
du problème a décidé d'aménager une
plaine de jeux
monsieur lemercier qui a conçu les plans
de cette plaine de jeux nous dit
pourquoi elle a été créée c'était un
problème de jeunesse car comme vous le
savez la ville de rennes a de plus en
plus de jeunes
et alors la municipalité a décidé de
faire un ensemble à breaking pour
justement satisfaire ses besoins et
satisfaire aussi le besoin des écoles
qui était construite bien avant la
guerre et qui eux qui elles n'avaient
pas d'équipement sportif
l'ensemble de ces mesures représente à
peu près ces hectares elle est conçue
comme ceci vous avez d'abord des plaines
de jeux quatre terrains de grands jeux
mais on peut faire de football capture
un grand jeu avec au centre de gym
brasse et tout autour d'une couronne de
vestiaires et de douches qui dessert en
même temps les gymnases et la plaine de
jeux à l'extrémité de cette l2 je vous
avais également aussi une piste
d'athlétisme
combien de jeunes pas venir ensemble par
exemple sur ces terrains ensemble on
peut accepter de 700 à 800 élèves
simultanément l'année dernière on a fait
la piscine il a commencé la piscine la
piscine nous sommes à l'heure actuelle
la elle a commencé en novembre 68
puissent-ils qui doit terminer en
novembre 70 pourquoi une piscine
olympique de 50 mètres bassin de 50
mètres le ministère avait décidé que
dans le fond tout ville le cent mille
habitants devra voir à bassin olympique
couvert et alors les études du début ont
été abandonnées et on l'a fait donc se
bat pour
qui a qui comprend un bassin de 50
mètres sur 21 bassins olympiques on peut
faire des compétitions nationales et
internationales et un bassin
d'entraînement d'initiation à la
natation qui fait 25 sur 10 elle sera
couverte ou découvert elle sera quand
entièrement couverte mais les gens
pourront aller à l'extérieur sur les
plages qui seront kazan et qui seront
toutes alentours de cette piscine en
annexe à la piscine elle même
il ya je crois un restaurant de prévu ni
un restaurant prévu où se trouve à
l'extrémité de la piscine il était allé
sur trois niveaux de façon que les gens
au maximum se rendre compte de toute
l'ampleur du bassin des plongeoirs ont
lu parfaite de la piscine quelle sera la
hauteur d'ensemble de cette piscine la
hauteur de la piscine a été donnée que
s'ils voulaient par la hauteur de
plongeurs olympique doit faire dit m
c'est obligatoire peut être 10 mètres au
dessus du plan d'eau on a une garde de
sécurité pour le plongeur de trois
mètres d'eau alors tout du plan d'eau au
plafond il y aura 13 mai ce qui nous
permet d'ailleurs de voir les gradins
jusqu'en haut et d'avoir des spectateurs
on pourra mettre environ 13 114
spectateurs plus de dégagements sur les
plages on pourra mais on pourrait
arriver à mettre 500 spectateurs très
facilement je pense que les jeunes de
rennes vous savez ils ont vraiment de la
chance d'avoir un établissement comme ça
car moi j'ai appris à nager à la piscine
de rennes en 1925 et on était à peu près
une dizaine le matin il y avait pas
beaucoup de monde tandis que maintenant
on n'a qu'à regarder ce qui se passe à
la piscine de m je suis sûr qu ici du
jeune gérant très nombreux d'ailleurs
une capacité de partout pour les quarts
pour les autos mêmes pour les deux abris
leur discipline